ce matin l'émotion était encore forte
dans ce quartier les habitants voient
les trafics de drogue au quotidien mais
ne s'attendait pas à une telle violence
à côté de chez eux en pleine rue on
voyait que ça a dégénéré
parce que où un peu le trafic comme
j'habitais ça fait peur quand même hein
ça fait par les gens qui se trouvent sur
le trottoir en béton comme ça à passer
c'est quand même dangereux
moi je sais que ça me fais pas ça assez
stressant 1 il est 19 heures hier soir
deux hommes sont pris pour cible l'un
d'eux est renversée et reçoit une balle
dans la poitrine
il mourra malgré l'intervention des
secours l'autre est poursuivi par les
agresseurs tous cagoulés
il est frappé à coups de barres de fer
et de marteaux il a été hospitalisé
les deux victimes âgées de 19 ans
viennent de la région parisienne
l'un au moins était connu pour trafic de
stupéfiants les faits se sont déroulés à
quelques mètres seulement de la mairie
de torcy
hier soir le maire est venu sur les
lieux et pour lui difficile de cacher
son émotion
ce jeune est décédé hier je n'avais vu
la semaine précédente souvent circulé
dans le quartier
c'était mal logement un jeune homme a
été presque normal qu'il est qu'il ait
eu ces activités c'est c'est très très
très dommage à ce matin une cellule de
crise s'est réunie en urgence à la
mairie objectif tenter d'apporter des
réponses pour la sécurité des habitants
et dès ce soir cinquante crs seront
déployés pour surveiller les différents
quartiers de la ville
pour l'instant c'est l'hypothèse du
règlement de compte qui est privilégiée
les investigations se poursuivent une
enquête a été ouverte et confiée à la
police judiciaire de dijon